open line will not be enough for the
black rook because the king can just
stop any entry squares but more than
that i think actually any winning
attempts pushing a pawn are actually
going to backfire on prague we would
just see a trader pawns and now white is
the one creating a past pawn
um let's i mean i want to say let's
catch up with the current position but
nothing at all is changing here ding is
offering that trade of rooks which we
mentioned would end the game in a draw
instantly if the rooks come off dead
draw we're going to find out is prague
going to try and win or is he just going
to trade rooks and admit that today has
not gone well
oh his webcam is a little off we can see
keeps rooks on the board yeah that's
good but we're going to see the players
repeat the moves and uh here we go ding
does take the first day
it's over
winning two games dingley ran is the
winner of the first match in the big
final we didn't see a big celebration he
immediately left the computer but i do
suspect a little bit of a celebration of
the camera playing a great match to